presqu'au johann strauss c'est un lieu
hautement symbolique où les ukrainiens
mènent tous leurs combats
aujourd'hui la place de l'indépendance à
qui avait été remplie de milliers de
citoyens concernés les étudiants des
nationalistes et des vétérans surtout
des bataillons entiers qui lutte depuis
cinq ans dans l'est de l'ukraine pour
récupérer les territoires occupés par
les séparatistes pro russes entrent plus
grande crainte c'est qu'il crée une
capitaux de perdre notre indépendance
non la capitulation gloire à l'ukraine
ce sont les slogans qui retentissent
partout à kiev
aujourd'hui un mouvement de protestation
un message pour un président qui a été
élu avec la promesse de mettre fin à la
guerre dans l'est de l'ukraine mais
qu'on accuse aujourd'hui d'aller
beaucoup trop vite pour profit de la
bourse
le président d'ukraine volodymyr de
lenski qui étaient sur la ligne de front
aujourd'hui a bel et bien signé une
entente avec moscou dans laquelle la
région sous le contrôle rebelle pourrait
éventuellement devenir autonomes mais
seulement au terme d'élections locales
libres dit il ya condition que les
troupes pro russe recul avant mais pour
ceux qui habitent la zone de conflit
comme natalia c'est un piège que tant la
russie je ne t'ai pas confiance à coude
il dit elle sa parole ouvrière il pour
cet analyste
le risque est énorme soit de légitimiser
dit il une occupation selon les termes
de moscou avec le pouvoir pro-russe
c'est à dire ils peuvent former leur
police
l'or s'est mis armés alors juge et c'est
donc ce serait un enclave russe contrôlé
par des ruses dans le territoire de
l'ukraine
bien sûr pour beaucoup des ukrainiens
c'est inacceptable
et ce mouvement de protestation ne
décolère pas si les ukrainiens ont voté
pour la paix en choisissant zelensky ses
citoyens refusent aujourd'hui tout
comprenez
si thammarat altéré secours est du
canada